RYAN BOYD: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
Michael Manoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And we're from our
Developer Relations Team for
Cloud Data Services.
And next week at Google I/O,
we're going to have a number
of sessions on our cloud
data services.
And we're super excited to share
these sessions with you.
And we hope that during this
quick video today, we can show
you which sessions that we'll
have and go a little bit
beyond the abstracts and give
you some information that will
be helpful for you to decide
which sessions to attend.
And hopefully you can
attend all of them.
But first of all, Michael, can
you just give a quick overview
of our cloud data services?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Sure.
The goal of Google's cloud
products has always going to
expose our scalable
infrastructure for developers
to use to build their
own applications.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about some of the
different technologies we have
available, including data
store, BigQuery, a new product
we've released, and also how
to put them together and build
your own web apps on this
technology.
RYAN BOYD: Wow.
Fantastic.
So hopefully all of you are
coming to I/O. If not, catch
some of these sessions
on video.
The Google I/O keynotes, I
believe, will be streamed.
And some of the sessions
will be.
I'm not sure if these will.
But hopefully they'll all be on
YouTube for you to watch if
you don't see them
at I/O itself.
So we want to go through each
of these sessions that we're
going to have.
And we'll talk a little bit
about them and hopefully get
you excited as we are.
So the first session that we're
going to have is Big
Data: Turning Your
Data Problem Into
a Competitive Advantage.
This is actually be done
by two of our product--
[INAUDIBLE]
who's the PM for Google
Cloud Storage.
And they're gonna really go into
the different business
problems that you have
with big data.
It used to be that pretty much
everyone in the world was
dealing with just very small
data sets, and only companies
the size of Google internet
scale were dealing with very
large data sets.
But nowadays pretty much
everyone has a chance to get a
large data set.
If you launch your new mobile
app, and it gets on to the
home page of the Android market,
you might really get
massive amounts of data that
you can use to improve your
applications.
And so they're gonna be talking
about the business
problem here and show
you which of our
tools can be used.
It mixes a little bit of
business and technology.
It's really for those chief
architects or CTO-level folks
who want to learn about
Google services.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's a
great introduction to the big
data space.
I think if you're interested in
that you should definitely
come to this talk.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, absolutely.
And they're also going
to have some external
speakers come up.
And one of those speakers is
one of the founders of
[? Beam. ?]
And [? Beam ?]
is a visualization company.
And they're one of the two
companies that earlier this
week launched some visualization
demos.
You should all check them out
if you didn't see those.
But they launched some
visualization demos showing
how you can do data
visualization on top of really
massive data sets of half
a billion rows of
data on top of BigQuery.
And so the founder of [? Beam ?]
is going to come up
and show you their tool and show
you how it was used for a
large retail company.
And then the folks at
Crystalloids, another external
presenter, are going to come up
and talk about how they use
this technology.
They're kind of like a
systems integrator.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
I've seen their demo, and they
have a great web application
dashboard for the hospitality
industry.
It's really exciting.
All built on top of BigQuery.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So this is a good session.
It mixes a little bit of
technology with the overall
business problems that you're
trying to solve.
So I definitely suggest
checking that out.
And then the next session of
course you should check out
because yours truly is going
to be giving it.
But first I want to give you a
little bit of an overview on
the cloud data space and
what Google aims to
do with these services.
And this is a quote from
one of our customers.
A large advertising customers
said, "By the time we prepared
the data, we've forgotten what
the question was." And this is
a problem when you're dealing
with a lot of upfront costs,
both costs in terms of money
but also in terms of people
and set up and all that
you have with
typical on-premise solutions.
And this is why we love the
cloud data solution space is
because Google offers services
that really allow you to get
up and running quickly
and dive in in an ad
hoc iterative fashion.
And you won't forget what
the question was.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
sometimes what we say at
Google is, worry about your
application, not the
infrastructure itself.
RYAN BOYD: Exactly.
So the next session that
I was talking about--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I heard
this was a good one.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So I'm giving this session
on crunching
big data with BigQuery.
And I'm doing it along with
one of the folks from our
BigQuery Engineering Team,
Jordan Tigani.
And this session really will
give you everything you need
to know about BigQuery.
And it's going to get for
those people that are of
intermediate knowledge in the
space, technical folks, but
then really dive deep for those
people-- those data
geeks like ourselves
that really
want to know the details.
So I'll give you some
examples here.
BigQuery is an analytic service
that allows you to
analyze large amounts of data.
And it's based off of
a REST-based API.
And we're gonna talk about
that REST API.
But we're also going to be
talking about some of the
public data sets that we make
available with BigQuery that
everyone here that's listening
here today can go in and play
around with.
And the main public dataset
we're going to go into is the
natality dataset.
And this is a record of all
the births in the US in, I
think, the last 40 years.
And you can really dive into
that data and see when people
were born, what states they
were born in, and go down
based off of the age of the
mother and things like that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I've seen
the outline for this talk, and
I think it's really
incredible.
The two things I've heard from
developers about BigQuery is
that it's both fun and
empowering to use.
And you're going see how to
build web applications using
it and use it for analysis.
It's gonna be great.
RYAN BOYD: And so one of the
demos we're actually going to
show here is using Google
Apps Script to
interact with BigQuery.
And this is a quick little demo
I built that analyzes
some trends in births
given by mothers.
They're first births given by
mothers, and what the weight
of the baby was and what the
age of the mother was.
And I break this down by red
state versus blue state.
I just thought it'd be kind of
fun, but I'm not going to give
you all the answers here.
But there definitely is
some differences.
Michael--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
People will have to either come
to the to talk or watch
it on video to get
the real answer.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So there's definitely some
differences in the age of the
mother at first birth between
blue states and red states and
differences even in the
weight of the baby.
So that's gonna be
kind of fun.
And I used Google Apps
Script for this.
But then the real core geek part
of this session is going
to be Jordan Tigani's part.
And Jordan is going to really
dive into the underlying
architecture of BigQuery.
And it's fascinating really.
So a lot of these technologies
Google built internally
because there wasn't any other
technology for us to solve our
data problems.
So we built the underlying
technology called Dremel and
released it as BigQuery
for public use.
And Jordan is going to really
dive into how that works, with
generally the hope that
understanding how the
underlying technology
works will help you
optimize your queries.
And just to give you a little
hint of one of the diagrams
from Jordan's part of the talk
is this is the architecture of
a query and how it goes through
the various mixers,
workers, and shards
in BigQuery.
And he'll explain all
how that works.
And then dive into some really
complex SQL queries to do
things like seven-day active
users of the GitHub dataset,
another one of those
public datasets.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
That's one of the most popular
datasets that we have.
Yeah.
And you're going to learn
a lot from this talk.
Like I said, I saw
the outline.
And it's a great technical
overview of this type of
technology.
RYAN BOYD: So hope you all can
make it to that one as well
and see me but maybe more
importantly is coming to see
Michael at the next talk.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Here's a talk you
definitely should come see.
So I'm going to talk about
putting all of these
technologies together.
So I'm going to talk about Data
Pipelines at Google Scale.
So in a practical sense, when
you build these applications
with big data you need to use
technologies that's optimized
for each step in the collection
of data, extracting
data, transforming data, and
then the analysis of it, as
well as the story.
So I'm going to talk to you
about using Google's
infrastructure to build
end-to-end applications that
use a collection of
technologies, including the
AppEngine-MapReduce Library for
doing data transformations
on a large scale.
And I'll show you some examples
of using data store
App Engine to collect data and
serve a web application and
pipe that data into Google
BigQuery for analysis.
So I hope you can join us.
You're going to learn a lot.
If you're just new to the big
data space, I think this is a
great overview for
the different
technologies available.
And if you've actually done a
lot of MapReduce or big data
transformations, come see how
you can implement this type of
technology on top
of App Engine.
RYAN BOYD: And this is
technology that we're
definitely using internally
ourselves.
We met with one of our senior
engineers a couple weeks ago.
And he was going into how he
used MapReduce on App Engine
to get his data transformed
and break it down to power
some Google products.
So it's pretty fascinating.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
It's great stuff.
So, yeah.
Please stop by or watch
on the video later.
Oh, and then we're
going to have a
hands-on code lab as well.
So on day one we're going to
talk about actually building
an application that uses
the app engine
logs as the data source.
And so we're going to talk about
building one of these
applications that's an
end-to-end data pipeline,
starting with your own Google
app engine logs of your own
application, piping that data
into Google cloud storage, and
then finally, the last step
is to put it into
BigQuery for analysis.
So you're going to sit down with
some Google engineers.
We have a bunch of Google
engineers, including some of
the engineers talking at Google
I/O on some of the big
data talks.
And we're going to show you
how to actually sit down,
write the code, and build
your own applications.
So definitely check it out.
RYAN BOYD: And the next session
we want to preview for
you is a session that's done by
the PM of the Google Cloud
Storage team, [INAUDIBLE],
Empowering Your Application's
Data Using Google
Cloud Storage.
Now Google Cloud Storage
is something
that's fairly simple.
But we've actually given you a
lot of power and flexibility
in this tool.
And we're releases more and more
features to really enable
you to build rich applications
that have a lot of
unstructured data.
You can store tons of data
in Google Cloud Storage.
I think it's about five
terabytes, I believe, for the
maximum size of an individual
object.
So a lot of data can
be stored up there.
And you can access it from a
lot of these other services
that we're talking about here.
So for instance, if you do stuff
on AppEngine-MapReduce
you can output the results of
that to Google Cloud Storage.
And then BigQuery can actually
read in the data from Google
Cloud Storage.
So [INAUDIBLE] gonna go really
into the details here of how
cloud storage works, how the
permissions model works, and
some other things, especially
some new features that you
might be interested in if you
store large amounts of
unstructured data.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We
have another fun talk.
So App Engine allows several
options for storing data when
you build a web application.
We have a SQL, a relational
data store.
And also the data store itself
is a NoSQL data store.
And so this talk is going
to talk about some of
the pros and cons.
It's called Battle
of the Backends.
And we're going to finally
decide which is the best for
your web application.
And surely Ryan, you agree that
SQL is the best method to
store your data.
RYAN BOYD: Oh, Michael.
Michael, Michael .
How naive you are.
It really--
the NoSQL solution, the
App Engine data
store, is just amazing.
It's very fluid schema.
And I can put lots of data in
it, lots of transactions.
Scales really well.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's highly
available, but what
about consistency.
You gotta admit that--
RYAN BOYD: Oh, Michael, come
on, you and your--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
--consistency is most important.
RYAN BOYD: Oh, no.
Michael.
So definitely.
Data store is the best one.
You should definitely use data
store for all your--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: One word
for your transactions.
That's all I'm gonna say.
RYAN BOYD: All right.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Anyway,
I guess you'll have to
come to this talk.
We're going to have an engineer
from both teams talk
about the pros and cons of both
and when to choose the
particular technology for
your web application.
RYAN BOYD: And believe it or
not, they actually agree on
some use cases which are
good for each of them.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I can't believe it.
RYAN BOYD: We looked at the
slides for this session.
And there is some
agreement there.
Apparently they've come to
some consensus, its--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: You might
even be able to build an
application that uses both.
We'll see.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
They'll talk about some
of those use cases
where you can use both.
But it should be a really fun
session, like all of these.
We're data geeks at heart.
So of course any session that's
about data technologies
we get really excited about
and we hope you'll get
excited about too.
We do actually have
Google Moderator.
And if you're looking at
the live stream here--
I'm going to check to see if
anyone's asked any questions.
I forgot to point that out to
you at the beginning of the
session here.
But hopefully some of you have
asked some questions that we
can take a look at.
Let's see here.
Actually doesn't look like we
have any questions here.
But maybe we'll wait
a moment and see if
anyone has any questions.
And then if not, we'll
just wrap things up.
But we really look forward to
seeing you all at Google I/O.
In addition to all these
sessions, there's some great
social events.
We also do have a sandbox
where a lot of external
third-party companies are going
to come in and show off
the things that they've been
building on top of our cloud
technologies.
A lot of things on App Engine
and on BigQuery and Google
Cloud Storage.
So there's some great third
parties that are coming and
really show off what
they build.
And hopefully you guys can
talk with them about what
you're building and share some
knowledge with them and get
some knowledge from them.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We
definitely love meeting
developers and seeing what
you're building and what your
data challenges are.
Just talking to you guys helps
us refine our products and
lets us learn what you guys are
building and how you can
build your applications
on our infrastructure.
So look forward to meeting
you there.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
It doesn't look like we have any
questions coming in here.
Although I just did tell you
about Moderator, so we'll see.
But I think we should
probably wrap it up.
And if you do have any
questions, we've actually been
really active on Stack Overflow
recently and BigQuery.
And I believe they're using that
for App Engine as well.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yep.
RYAN BOYD: So if you do have
any questions about these
technologies, feel free to ask
them on Stack Overflow.
And we'll all dive in
and try to help.
And the community's been
really active.
And we have to say thank you for
everyone in the community
that's been really active
answering questions there too.
It certainly allows us to
prepare for these Google I/O
sessions and things like that.
So ask your questions
on Stack Overflow.
Here's our Google+
profiles as well.
You can reach out to
us on Google+.
And I'll do one last refresh
here and see if there's been
any questions.
Can we please share
the slides?
Yes, we can share the slides.
I will post them on my Google+
stream after the end.
And Michael will probably
as well.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
And by the way, you can go to
the Google I/O website and see
when the sessions are
all going to be.
And I believe all the sessions
we talked about are going to
be available on YouTube
shortly after
they're given, right?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
I don't know the exact timing,
but in the past we've at least
published our sessions
on YouTube.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So don't
worry if you're not actually
going to Google I/O.
You'll be able to
see all these sessions.
And we usually publish the code
related to the sessions
and other materials.
So you're going to be
able to see it all.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
So since we did get one
question, I'll refresh here.
And no.
It looks like that's all the
questions that we have here.
So we'll wrap it up.
And thank you very much
for attending today.
And we look forward to seeing
you at Google I/O if you're
going to be there.
Otherwise, we look forward
to seeing you online.
Take care.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Bye, everyone.